[Music]
and
this time the pair jetted off to montana
for a weekend getaway
it feels really good and it's really
nice according to multiple sources
jennifer lopez and ben affleck vacation
together alone at the yellowstone club
in montana for a week
the two were spotted riding in a car
together the actor was driving while
j.lo was riding shotgun
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment
we started working of course this all
raises the question
are they back together well this is what
we know a source tells et quote
j.lo and ben have natural chemistry when
they're together
they have a good time when they're
hanging out and things have been easy
fun and exciting between them staying
present in the moment
and enjoying all of the wonderful things
that are happening right now
the source adds that the pair have
stayed in touch over the years
so reconnecting isn't a huge surprise to
their friends
ben is protective over jlo and they're
trying to be as low-key as possible
it was my first kind of heartbreak it
was just one of those things you know i
was an adult
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like a tough one for me
ben and jen split in 2004
after a two-year engagement but have
remained friendly ever since
j.lo is no stranger to keeping it
cordial with her exes
she's still close to marc anthony as
they co-parent their two children
the singer was also spotted having
dinner with most
recent ex alex rodriguez after the two
announced their breakup last month
i'm just taking it one day at a time
meanwhile
ben has also done the same keeping it
cool with his ex-wife jennifer gardner
as the two shared three children
together let me do our best we don't try
our best ben
gave the actress a shout out on mother's
day writing on instagram
so happy to share these kids with you
thanks for all the good you do
it's so important that you model for
your kids
a source recently told et that garner
isn't bothered by ben
hanging out with j.lo or anyone else she
wants what is best for ben